j'appréhende de faire cette vidéo je
vous explique depuis que je suis jeune
j'ai une malédiction h f il n'y a pas
une année qui passe sans que quelqu'un
m'offre un casse-tête sais pas pourquoi
alors c'est cool c'est un cadeau donc
c'est cool c'est agréable mais il ya
comme un petit pick up un petit coup de
couteau qui va avec puisque les gens
savent que j'adore la difficulté mais
savent aussi que je suis pas sûr du tout
et je suis un gros rageux je dois vous
avouer quelque chose là tous ceux qui
m'ont offert ça dans ma vie à la fois
j'espère vous regardez la vidéo à la
fois j'espère vous la gardez pas je n'en
ai jamais fini un sol
arrêtez de m'offrir des castels je ne
sais pas défini aujourd'hui c'est un peu
comme ce que j'ai fait avec le dessin
dans la vidéo vous arracher plus élevé
au dessin donc je suis trop content
c'était vraiment adapté je me suis dit
gens vont pas aimer mais au moins moi je
me serais tu es passé je me suis fait
plaisir aujourd'hui j'ai acheté 4 casse
tête qui sont pas facile donc pour moi
impossible de les finir j'ai pas pris
des casse têtes comme offert parce que
j'étais trop engagé dessus et c est ça
me saoule et je préfère découvrir avec
vous le casse tête et c'était des
cassettes plus ou moins originaux avec
des mécaniques différentes et en tout
cas qui m'inspire qui me donne envie
d'essayer
donc c'est déjà ça de pris cast est
numéro un on y va bon voici le premier
casse-tête
il s'agit du réseau c'est une clé dans
une clé est donc là la mécanique s'est
il faut le désassembler les réassembler
croix dessus elle est très très très
connus dont peut-être qu'un certain flou
qui le connaissent et j'aimerais bien le
finir très vite très rapidement alors
deux clés et le but c'est de les sortir
et mehr m ouais ok il faut réussir à le
faire basculer
voyez ça c'est l'étape 1 c'est l'étape
qu'on est un peu passionné donc ça se
présente comme ça à mon avis le truc
c'est le savez ces trucs de rotation on
tourne depuis du coup ça passe puis on
peut on peut passer l'autre côté puis
machin mais ça finit par se désassembler
ça c'est l'analyse d'un expert des casse
tête ça se voit n'est ce pas déjà j'ai
un réflexe bizarre j'ai envie de tirer
j'ai envie de tirer comme ça très fort
un bon réflexe de gros rageux de merde
hein n'est ce pas quand la clé à la
verticale
ça passe là quand la clé et à
l'horizontale ça va ce nul pas on peut
pas passer de l'autre côté parce que la
boule est trop grande
voyez ça bloque de l'autre côté on peut
passer que de ce côté là mais une fois
qu'on est là mais je ne sais pas quoi
faire ça c'est fait pour arriver là mais
quand tu arrives là à quoi ça sert
et dans l'autre sens auo il vient de se
passer quelque chose là regardez je vous
remonte soit je mets ce comme ça et je
peux passer là ce qui nous a amenés à
rien soit je lève la clé je peux passer
là et là c'est une nouvelle étape quoi
ça nous sert de passer là je comprends
pas puisqu'on peut pas passer la bon
bref fois la clé à la verticale elle
peut passer partout
attends attends quoi attend il s'est
passé quoi là j'ai réussi à la mettre
comme ça je passe la première barre
n'est pas la deuxième est en train de
tirer toujours plus simple de tirer que
de réfléchir ça c'est une règle toujours
beaucoup plus sympa temps mais j'ai
réussi à aller là ça amène à ok je
reviens je le fais dans l'autre sens
j'ai compris pas du tout en fait j'ai
évoqué c'est ça mon problème je fais
plein de trucs comme ça une ligue 1 et
j'espère que ça passe et je suis je sais
pas où ça mène ce que je fais mais
j'espère que ça mène au fait que les
deux trucs se désassembler en réalité à
la fin je remets pas compris comment
j'ai fait c'est ça qui est débile c'est
idiot mais qu attendait donc déjà tout
alors j'avais réussi à amener la clé sur
la barre principal qu'elle a donc je
pense que ça c'est ce qui mène à la à la
solution ça on peut repasser et là on
passe la voilà je pense que ça c'est le
début ce que je comprends pas c'est que
la clé elle passe la première barre mais
elles passent pas la deuxième barre
voyez si bizarre est-ce que c'est fait
exprès parce que là si je passe cette
deuxième bar là je passe au bout c'est
fini est-ce qu'il n'y a pas quelques
lots de la clayette rue cameron a claqué
une fois qu'on est arrivé en haut de la
clé il faut la tourner je suppose oui
moi je suis en train de perdre le
contrôle je sais plus tout ce que je
suis en train de faire avec cette clé au
camden calme terre j'ai réussi à le
désassemblage pour montrer que tu as
compris me casse tête il faut être
capable de le ré assembler suite les
réassembler en deux temps trois
mouvements mon petit pote donc je sais
que l'entrée cela
donc tu commences avec les deux clés
comme ça je fais ça puis ça puis la nar
man tu peux passer ici ou ici
merde au nom la honte je ne sais pas
comment j'ai fait attends je vais
achever votre chèque le rush voir et
voilà pourquoi je n'arrivais pas à faire
les casse tête pendant tout ce temps il
faut que je me filme à pouvoir me
souvenir de ce que j'ai fait vraiment de
la triche bon après analyse des images
vous énervez pourquoi je n'arrivais pas
à le remettre parce que je m'obstine à
vouloir leur maître dans ce sens là et
du coup on fait ça passe nulle part
latéralement en fait il faut le remettre
dans ce sens là l'autre sens et là hop
ça passe voilà là ça passe on revient là
une fois qu'on est là on retourne la clé
voilà une fois que la clé retourner on
passe on repasse bon ben voilà vous avez
saisi l'idée quoi bon réanalyse des
images je vous montre comment on fait
pour le remonter en gros ici il faut
voir ça comme un petit portail et il ya
des trucs que j'avais pas vu au premier
abord mais c'est par exemple cette barre
elle est plus fine en bas qu'elle ne
l'est en eau donc en fait on peut sortir
la clé par en bas mais pas part aux
essais plein de petits détails comme ça
c'est vraiment bien fait je découvre ce
que c'est quoi un casse tête bien foutu
donc l'entrée du casse tête quand on
veut le recomposer c'est bien évidemment
là où on est sorti donc c'est la up
une fois qu'on a mis on le fait pas
c'est là une fois qu'ils passent là on
retourne de ce côté là j'en arrive là
une fois qu'on est là on fait ça une
fois qu'on est là on tourne la clé pour
pouvoir passer de l'autre côté
une fois qu'on est passé de l'autre côté
ont rendu une fois qu'on est rentré on
repasse là on retourne au point mais pas
échus un tueur j'ai fini
c'est l'heure du deuxième casse tête
[Musique]
est ce que cette vidéo est intéressant
elle est nerveuse droit je suis honnête
avec vous mais bon vous voyez rager
après tout ça depuis 2014 c'est quelque
chose qui allait alors ça mon pote ça je
sais que c'est horrible davinci
hélicoptère puzzle déjà le nom nous met
pas du tout en confiance
ah ça c'est exactement ce que je déteste
c'est tout le temps sur cela que j'ai
rage est alors une fois résolue le
puzzle sera en trois pièces est ce que
vous pouvez réussir à séparer
l'hélicoptère ok j'ai pas que léonard
s'amusait à faire des casse têtes
difficulté 3 sur 5
on note cette info on la note alors on a
une croix avec une petite pièce qui
bouge là et au milieu là il ya un trou
ici bon bah le but du coup vous allez
être surpris mais c'est de le démonter
tout simplement ont déjà qu'est ce qui
bouge là on voit bien que ça c'est lié
par le milieu ça ça change de sens est
ce que c'est un rectangle ou est ce que
c'est un carré de peau est intéressant
mais il est horrible mais c'est pas un
casse tête c'est un objet de décoration
quoi on le met comme ça hop c'est un
objet déco et on en parle plus quoi fin
pourquoi les gens veulent se faire chier
à démonter il est très bien comme ça
elles sont emboîtés l'une dans l'autre
là les deux plans je voyais là il ya un
trou dans ses là pour que cela puisse
rentrer et pareil de l'autre côté mais
je comprends pas comment on est censé
faire bouger les choses
un pour le mans je peux juste faire sa
star malta en fait et les redoutables
parce qu'il est simple quoi il ya trois
pièces trois bouts de bois là à temps
mais c'est ça les fameux bout de bois
clé qu'a joué nos parents quand ils
avaient le même âge que nous c'est cela
tu m'étonnes qu'ils ont passé leur
enfance à jouer avec son jamais compris
ça se trouve il ya un petit bouton caché
quelque part et quand on appuie dessus
hop'sasa se disloque et on obtient 3 ps
laissez moi rêver
on peut même pas les pousser dans ce
sens là où dans l'autre sens rien n'y
fait c'est terrible ça vient forcément
de la regarder le jeu qui à quoi
bizarre ce que je fais c'est juste une
mécanique de merde à trouver ça
cafouille vegas tête c'est toujours ça
ya juste un truc qui est hors de son
cercle de logique là et qui t'échappe
totalement qu'est ce que ce truc là
vient [ __ ] dans l'histoire et pourquoi
ils s'appellent hélicoptère à ce que
vous trouvez que ça ressemble vraiment
un hélicoptère suis pas sûr
m
vous me pardonnerez tôt ou tard vous me
pardonnerez pour ce que je vais faire
mr
comment tu fais comment tu fais c'est
quoi le truc qui m'a échappé
s'te plaît me dis pas que c'est un truc
tout con aucun texte ne sachant où il y
en a c'est un troll il l'étape 1 c'est
de faire ce à quoi ça est donc quoi flop
puce le temps fera pas partie mais je me
fais trop laissé un 1er avril ça a été
mis en ligne le 1er avril le 4 janvier
on est très loin d'un 1er avril
ouais d'accord on est d'accord que
premier degré ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas pour moi j'ai la solution
sous les yeux et je n'y arrive pas alors
mec ça me flingue j'ai la solution sous
les yeux et je n'y arrive pas qu est ce
qui se passe ici plutôt frais week-end
pour le tout prend mec c'est de la folie
ça fait quatre fois que j'ai regardé que
je sais que j'arrive pas
en peinture peinture comme de gauche le
troisième un mec j'ai là j'ai la
solution sous les yeux et ça ne marche
pas combien d'années mort et il fallut
combien de vies mort et il fallut pour y
arriver sans la solution aux eaux
achetez le htv fait le même si vous avez
l'asus maintenant ça vaut le coup un
bordel de merde mais quel enfer
mais du coup lui casser quoi le team
sont n'a pas compris et bien moi non
plus mais je vais essayer de vous
l'expliquer en grondant chaque bout là
vous voyez vous voyez une barre en fer
il y en a une de chaque côté en fait tu
voyais là on voit les deux par exemple y
en a une qui sort de la une qui sort de
là et en gros chaque bar va venir
s'enfoncer dans les trous que ya de part
et d'autre de l'autre pièce et quand tu
fais le mouvement qui fait là les deux
bars à tour de rôle
sorte de l'autre pièce ça permet
finalement de pouvoir faire sortir l'une
des deux pièces voilà écouter moins bien
je n'aurais jamais trouvé de toute une
existence c'est un 3 sur 5 ans les
difficultés 5 est casté numéro
j'ai mûri il m'en reste la regarde et me
reste 3 kw à 9 sur 10
le eureka attend 9 sur 10 ça va être des
histoires de tricks ça va être horrible
suis là je l'aimé bien parce qu'il est
très minimaliste et pourtant je pense
qu'il est extrêmement dur juste une
boule avec dépit qu'il faut réussir à
faire sortir la boule il est horrible
juste le regard des sommes de mal au
crâne ok et le dernier c'est une boîte
et ben on va faire la boîte donc
regarder que c'est juste une boîte
chaque côté ce n'est pas exactement la
même forme que vous avez là le but c'est
de les séparer on voit clairement quêtes
du jeu attendez je sais il faut le
prendre comme ça il faut mon cerveau de
l'homme primitif a tendance à vouloir
juste tirer comme ça mais ça à mon avis
il faut pousser d'un côté comme ça puis
de l'autre puis de l'autre puis de
l'autre farm la ville et pas du tout
simple ce casse-tête façon plus il a
l'air simple plus il est dur que c'est
horrible parce tu sais pas par où
commencer quoi mec c'est une boîte quoi
notamment tu mets deux bagues et des
boucles d'oreilles dedans et on en parle
plus mais la sk pas un truc de ressorts
ou [ __ ] et débile c'est bizarre mais vous
avez une idée qu'on tire ça marche pas
forcément quand on veut faire une
rotation latéral ça marche pas non plus
je pas non plus non mais les trucs ou
faut construire et déconstruire excès en
bois je vous jure c'est cela qui me
traumatise jure le point commun de tous
les casse tête qui me qui me rendent
malade c'est qu'ils sont en bois quoi je
sais pas pourquoi
voilà je commence avec les ongles dans
les trous pour tirer fort c'est pas du
tout bon signe ça mais je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire la vérité je n'ai
aucune [ __ ] d'idée de commandes par où
commencer même pas de commentaires ou de
par quoi commencer c'est comme l'autre
club
attendez je vais tenter un truc
dans un discours il faut toujours
frapper ou secouer est ce que c'est
possible ne voit rien n'a frappé ou
secouer
c'est trop pour moi
bon explication on a donc deux parties
est en fait dans chaque partie il ya un
petit trou celui-là est profond celui là
n'est pas profond et on a une bille
labit joue un rôle très important
puisqu'en fait pour remettre le casse
tête tu la mets là il ya deux petits
aimants au fond de chaque trou est en
fait qu on va leur mettre la bi va
entrer à moitié dans l'autre trou ce qui
fait qu'on pourra pas séparer les boues
et il faut mettre un gros coup pour
qu'elles passent dans la partie rouge
donc pour refaire le casse tête
on met la vie dans la partie rouge ça se
glisse tout simplement en diagonale
comme ça on retourne aux mains un petit
coup là où il ya la bi voilà on a
entendu un ptit clap etc rebloqué c'est
bien mais en fait ça me frustre parce
que du coup au final il faut juste
trouver ben il faut juste trouver ou
taper quoi c'est pas une mécanique qui
moins amusé par exemple je me suis
beaucoup plus s'amuser avec la clé vous
êtes parce que je les réussis et que je
suis extrêmement de mauvaise foi
actuellement les amis épreuve finale on
va pas faire celui là on va faire le
eurek'art j'ai peut-être pris beaucoup
fort la confiance en voyant la solution
de d2 truc d'avant mais j'assume
on a donc une sculpture en bois avec un
trou au milieu et une ficelle chacune
des extrémités est passé du coup a
priori dans le tout fin c'est ce qu'on
croit et bien entendu ni la boule qui se
trouve là ni la pièce qui est au bout ah
si ok les disques passe mais pas la
boule donc comment on fait et on a en
plus de ça un anneau en bas il a l'air
mais gadjo mais aulas va chier un taux
de magic est comme ça ou c'est une
ficelle tu fais un noeud est un anneau
qui est là au milieu et en fait nos
effets d'une telle façon ou en fait il
est fait autour de l'anneau et du coup
tu peux sortir l'anneau voilà je pense
qu'il s'était très clair mais du coup je
pense qu'il ya un délire dans ce genre
là et que celui là puisqu'on retrouve
l'anneau là et la ficelle et ça m'a tout
de suite fait penser à ça donc je pense
qu'il ya une corrélation en tout cas je
vais tout donner pour y arriver et
j'espère vous faire honneur peu importe
le temps qu'il faudra je réserverai ce
puzzle eureka notée 9 sur 10 c'est parti
[Musique]
mais c'était interminable mec
bon vous avez hâte de voir la solution
et j'ai hâte de vous la montrer
est ce que le but bien sûr c'est que je
vous montre comment faire pour le
remonter bien sûr on l'a dit au début on
n'a pas résolu à castétis on n'arrive
pas à le remonter
parce que ça peut être de la chance
alors écoutez c'est très simple vous
allez juste prendre la noë posé là non
sur l'accord vous allez appuyer bien
fort avec votre doigt ici sur le palais
et dans l'anneau avec vos deux index
vous allez tirer sur la corde voile à
partir de là c'est plutôt ça vous remet
et elano sur le sueur l'objet vous
retirez la boule qui pose problème
depuis le départ vous passez votre
petite ficelle dans l'objet vous mettez
la boule vous remettez le disque et
c'est terminé
merci à tous à bientôt bon blague à part
merci déjà d'avoir suivi cette vidéo que
je retiens quand même c'est que j'ai
réussi à finir un casse-tête et s'était
jamais arrivé avant je vous assure alors
oui la difficulté c'est que 2 sur 6 mais
bon il faut bien commencer quelque part
mais j'ai quand même réussi à faire cela
donc rester tranquille restez à votre
place ok vous m'en direz des nouvelles
quand vous l'aurez fille enlevée je suis
content parce que j'ai découvert des
mécaniques par exemple le fait de devoir
taper de devoir secoué dans le cas de
l'ecovio l'hélico merde et jusqu'à la
fin je suis désolé je suis comme ça un
casse-tête plus classiques comme celui
là j'ai réussi à finir alors oui c'est
plus simple je suis quand même content
parce que je les fais sans tricher et là
ya pas de de mécanique caché à
comprendre tout est sous tes yeux c'est
juste des chemins à prendre des
rotations à trouver j'ai beaucoup
apprécié donc je pense dans un premier
temps je me dirigeais plus vers ce genre
de casse tête là et j'ai mettre de côté
cela mais le fait d'en avoir fini 1
enfin après tant d'années me donne envie
d'en essayer d'autres je sais pas si
t'es cool pour vous mais ça m'a fait
marrer j'ai découvert des mécaniques des
trucs probable en ce moment je me sers
de ma chaîne youtube pour prendre sur
moi sur des trucs qui m'ont toujours
frustré voile après la vidéo comme ça
c'était celle avec le dessin la deuxième
c'est avec les casse-têtes la troisième
qu'est ce que ce sera je ne sais pas
aller pas de casse tête pour noël vous
avez bien entendu ceux qui me
connaissent la pâte casse tête pour noël
hockey est ce que je fais une vidéo sur
machine pour faire passer un message à
cette personne
oui
[Musique]